au Québec une ville des Laurentides
déploie un projet inusité chauffer et
climatiser un bâtiment avec les eaux
usées
c'est une histoire qui commence bien
avant le premier coup de pelle mécanique
avec une idée un peu farfelue on
appelait ça la caca thermique je sais
pas
très sérieux l'idée d'Alexandre Latour
c'est d'utiliser les eaux usées de
Sainte-Adèle comme source d'énergie pour
les nouveaux bureaux de son entreprise
on s'est dit pourquoi pas aller chercher
de l'énergie à même cette source d'eau
là qui est pas de l'eau propre mais qui
est de l'eau quand même qui a une
énergie qu'on voulait utiliser
et très rapidement c'est devenu une
histoire de famille mon frère a décidé
de se payer un laboratoire que moi je
suis bien content j'ai envie parce que
les deux dirigent une firme d'ingénieurs
devinez clatours de boutique Parisot
président directeur général Dominique
est dans le génie du bâtiment et
l'efficacité énergétique Alexandre
équipe Laurence Alexandre lui est
enterré connu avec les égouts et les
bassins d'épuration et ça a pris
l'expertise des deux pour transformer
des eaux brunes en énergie verte
c'est un peu un essai qu'on fait dans
notre projet là c'est pas ça pas été
vraiment réalisé le à ce qu'on sache au
Québec
au printemps 2021 le chantier se met en
branle à Sainte-Adèle dans les
Laurentides et aux commandes d'appels
mécanique il y a un troisième la tour
Bernard c'est notre Père qui fait
l'excavation suite à mon frère il prend
le projet très à coeur dans les
ordinateurs de Dominique les futurs
bureaux d'Alexandre existent déjà une de
ses spécialités c'est le chauffage et la
climatisation des bâtiments mais c'est
la première fois qu'on lui demandait de
puiser de la chaleur dans les eaux usées
c'est lui qui nous a qui nous a un petit
peu sorti notre zone de confort qui nous
a dit pourquoi on ferait pas ça puis
rapidement notre première réaction c'est
bien on a tué le droit parce que
d'habitude quand on veut faire de
l'hydrothermie c'est-à-dire récupérer de
la chaleur dans l'eau on pense plutôt à
des lacs ou à des rivières
que vous partez là c'est ça nous on est
parti en se disant l'eau normalement au
Québec comment qu'est-ce qu'on porte on
a travaillé avec ça puis l'hiver même à
penser que le réservoir est un peu plus
chaud qu'un lac normal il y a de
l'amener d'eau de l'activité qui
provient des égouts l'activité qui fait
sourire c'est évidemment celle-là mais
les maisons rejettent aussi de l'eau qui
provient de la douche du lavage de la
vaisselle ou autre bref l'eau qui se
retrouve dans le bassin d'épuration est
un peu plus chaude que celle d'un lac
c'est avec elle qu'on espère chauffer et
climatisé un bâtiment de trois étages
prévus pour 100 employés on commence par
voir l'enveloppe l'utilisation
l'enveloppe architecturale la
fenestration l'orientation l'occupation
à l'intérieur la quantité d'air frais
qu'on va qu'on va y admettre puis tout
ça là on va avoir un bâtiment où est-ce
qu'on va voir le sa charge énergétique
son profil énergétique au cours de
l'année puis après ça on va greffer les
systèmes mécaniques on va choisir les
meilleurs systèmes mécaniques pour cette
application là et d'après la
modélisation la chaleur du bassin d'oser
devrait suffire
[Musique]
mai 2021 on lance donc l'opération
forage l'objectif c'est de connecter le
bassin d'épuration et le futur bâtiment
avec deux tuyaux
en tout il y a 200 mètres à faire
l'opérateur suit une cible que son
collègue déplace pour guider la tête de
forage lui présentement est à 5 mailles
66 en arrière de moi il vient me
chercher il faut tout bien l'écran parce
que moi je mets la boîte en avant puis
lui sans ligne automatiquement les eaux
usées ne vont pas circuler dans le
bâtiment elle reste dans le bassin
les deux tuyaux servent à créer un
circuit fermé entre les deux avec à
l'intérieur du glycol un liquide antigel
qui transporte la chaleur il y a une
conduite qui amène les glycoles
jusqu'aux établisés puis une conduite
qui ramène les glycoles jusqu'au
bâtiment ou l'énergie soutirée pierre
est retournée
la boucle sert à déplacer de la chaleur
entre les deux en été pour climatiser
c'est la chaleur du bâtiment qu'on prend
et qu'on transfère au glycol en faisant
passer le tuyau dans le bassin la
chaleur se dissipe et le glycol remonte
plus frais
Alexandre Latour va récolter des données
sur les températures un peu partout dans
le système il va avoir des sondes on va
faire du monitoring on va faire des
validations pour être certain que on
regarde une trace de ce qui était faite
puis d'essayer de s'assurer que ça
fonctionne par exemple dans les
conduites des glycles on va en mettre
des sondes pour voir c'est quoi les
charges de chaleur combien qu'on va
gagner pour s'assurer que c'est bon puis
un peu de connaître c'est quoi le gain
d'énergie qu'on a fait
pour chauffer le bâtiment en hiver c'est
la chaleur du bassin qu'on veut utiliser
et ça se fait en deux étapes parce que
l'eau dans le bassin va être autour de 5
degrés Celsius le glycol qui remonte
aussi
l'idée c'est d'extraire un peu de son
énergie quelques degrés et de le
retourner au bassin pour qu'il se
réchauffe et reviennent à 5 degrés à
chaque cycle on récupère donc un peu
d'énergie cette énergie sert à
réchauffer du glycol dans une deuxième
boucle fermée à l'intérieur du bâtiment
le glycol va circuler dans les tuyaux
des planchers chauffants
au fil des semaines le bâtiment prend
forme avec la structure d'acier le toit
et les fenêtres
[Musique]
pendant l'hiver on se concentre sur les
travaux à l'intérieur la date de
déménagement des employés d'Alexandre
Latour approchent
l'hiver sera particulièrement froid et
long
[Musique]
et il fallait attendre le printemps pour
installer la pièce maîtresse du système
un peu nerveux oui
on a passé à tout mais c'est le jour J
comme ils disent ouais c'est grand jour
l'installation de la chambre qui était
sur c'était pas trop payé mais c'est
l'installation des toutes les couilles
ce sont des bobines de tuyau qui vont
serpenter dans les eaux usées au total
on en installe 12 ça donne environ 3.5
km de conduite
on l'avait comme jamais vraiment
réfléchi là le principe c'est
d'augmenter la surface de contact pour
maximiser l'échange d'énergie entre le
glycol dans les tuyaux et les eaux usées
qui arrivent dans le bassin
deux semaines plus tard les employés
s'installent les premiers tests vont
donc se faire en été donc le système
réagit étrangement très très bien
passé longtemps
la surprise c'est que l'échange de
chaleur est encore meilleur que prévu
d'après les premiers résultats avec le
même bassin et la même quantité de
serpentins on pourrait chauffer et
climatiser un deuxième bâtiment
moi j'ai confiance que l'hiver l'État va
être plus performant qu'on avait imaginé
il y a moins de risques qu'on y va qu'on
avait imaginé ça va très bien performer
cet hiver l'autre bonne nouvelle c'est
que la présence de tuyau n'a pas
d'impact négatif sur le bassin
d'épuration parce que ça aurait pu
refroidir la municipalité et miner le
projet c'est toujours quand tu es le
premier pas quelque chose pourquoi
personne l'a faite raison on a cherché
on a cherché on a cherché on a cherché
des études de d'universitaire qui avait
été faite là-dessus puis les raisons
dont les côtés négatifs de
ce système là on a réussi à les
contrôler puis aller à les éviter ou
presque des études universitaires il va
peut-être y en avoir plus les données
qu'il récoltent intéresse des chercheurs
et évidemment son frère
ça prenait quelqu'un qui avait le goût
de d'investir et puis de prendre le
risque puis ça c'est grâce à mon frère
mais c'était un risque qui a été
stressant plusieurs pendant plusieurs
mois même année mais on est on est
content du résultat puis maintenant nous
autres on est capable on a tout en main
toutes les données pour faire des
systèmes optimisés puis c'est sûr qu'on
va le répéter ailleurs ailleurs au
Québec et au Canada pourquoi je suis au
Canada
partout dans sa planète les eaux usées
en de partout d'ailleurs à Sherbrooke et
dans les Laurentides d'autres projets
sont déjà sur la planche à dessin et
leur source d'inspiration c'est l'idée
pas si farfelue d'Alexandre Latour
[Musique]